Haakon: Hello YouTube.
We have been focusing on dignity.
Global dignity is something [inaudible] of
Finland and general Bryant of the US and myself
have started.
What we're doing is we're focusing on dignity
as a core value.
That we to be, we want it to be a base so
that we can actually go out and make the right
decisions.
So that dignity in leadership, dignity in
decision making.
And the idea is that it's possible to actually
increase other people's dignity.
A type of dignity capital.
So that if you actually lift people up, you
can increase other people dignity.
The beauty of that is of course that then
also your own dignity is increased.
So we've taken this idea and we've gone into
schools all around the world.
And talking to kids about what dignity means
to them.
We ask them to define dignity in their own
words and also ask them to tell stories of
dignity from their own lives.
And come up with suggestions for what they
would like to do the next year to increase
other people dignity.
So I was in Jordan awhile ago, and in my class,
the class I was assigned to, there was a girl.
And she told a story about her teacher who
was visually impaired.
This was in her elementary school, and she
was a very ambitious student, so she was a
bit annoyed because this teacher, she wasn't
able to use the blackboard, she wasn't able
to catch students if they were sending notes
and so forth.
And she thought she would be better off with
a better teacher.
[pause]
So she was a bit annoyed.
She moved on to junior high-school, and she
read in the paper that this teacher was actually
the first visually impaired person in Jordan
to gain a PH.D, and her whole perspective
changed.
She now became proud that this had been her
teacher.
Her teacher's success became her success.
And I thought that that was just a beautiful
story how first of all there's more than meets
the eye to every single one of us.
Every person has dignity.
and secondly, that there's so much more you
learn in the educational system then just
math and the curriculum.
There's something else that’s about values,
about who we are as human beings, that is
really core and essential in creating the
world we want for the future.